في الضفه الغربيه افادت وزاره الصحه
الفلسطينيه باستشهاد ثلاثه فلسطينيين
واصابه اثنين عشر اخرين بنيران قوه
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي خلال اقتحامها مخيمه
بلاطه شرقيه مدينه نابلس اكبر المخيمات
الفلسطينيه في الضفه فجر اليوم وبحسب
الهلال الاحمر ووزاره الصحه الفلسطينيين
فان احد الجرحى حالته حرجه وكانت قوات
اسرائيليه اقتحمت المخيم تقدمتها قوات من
الوحدات الخاصه اضافه الى جرافات عسكريه
وافاد الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني بان قوه
الاحتلال اعاقت عمل طواقمه
وقد افادت الاذاعه الاسرائيليه الرسميه
بان مئات الجنود شاركوا في عمليه اقتحام
مخيم بلاطه شرقيه نابلس شجره اليوم وقالت
الاذاعه ان قوات مشتركه من لواء دفعاتي
ووحداتي
الخاصه وجهاز الشبك نفذت هذه العمليه